Mikhail kazanov he was prime minister of
Russia from 2000 and 2004 is now a
Critic of Vladimir Putin and good
morning to you does this feel like the
start of a civil war to you in Russia
well I wouldn't say Civil War that that
starts at the beginning of the collapse
of Putin's regime of course Mr Putin
himself created this program it was
inevitable that such a crisis will come
and I just even last year I predicted
this and in fact just precaution is
Putin's friend who got a responsibility
ability from Putin to help him to get
some Victorious a little Victorious
victories from the battlefield with the
grain and in fact in fact Mr Putin
somehow created a conflict between the
official militaries and these masonry's
group Wagner and in fact right now this
precaution goes beyond his expectation
that's why Putin has nothing to do
around than just to to press and
absolutely destroy this this group that
will happen within one two days I I
think that will be done if not that
beginning beginning of collapse of
regime would there would develop very
rapidly
interesting and what will be going on um
other than what's happening outwardly in
terms of his his attempt to try and put
this uh Rebellion down what's going on
internally would you suspect I mean
President Putin is known to be paranoid
he's known to be isolated
what will be being planned for him
personally in uh internally right now
just all if we can say leaders or
whatever just visible people in power
and different positions now pressed to
demonstrate publicly to demonstrate
loyalty to Mr puto everybody
including cut the Earth who already said
just that he's prepared to send his
military groups to to fight the
precaution just to stop his operation
this military coup whatever we can call
him yeah that's what that's what uh
coming going on right now just everyone
all these presenters on televisions all
critics of um of um
uh Mr precaution uh before all
supporters of Mr precaution including
just those people from from the
parliament now they had to demonstrate
loyalty to Putin and to condemn
precaution that's what's going now and
they already started the military
started to bomb just the the highway
from Crimea and from rustov to Moscow so
that to prevent any movement on these
highways of of military trucks to Moscow
well if the goal is to isolate Mr
pagodian here I mean the video that
shows him seemingly in cordial
conversation with senior members of the
Russian military what do you make of
that because if he manages to turn
significant factions of the Russian
military
then he's pretty powerful
uh in fact in fact uh there's
I think we are losing that line again
um we will try to
re-establish that line with Mr kazinoff
with former prime minister of Russia
until 2004. I'm sorry Mr casinov I need
to ask you to repeat your answer to that
question I was just asking whether you
think it's realistic that Mr pragodian
can effectively uh co-opt the Russian
military that video where he seems to be
in cordial conversation with senior
members of the Russian military
um does beg the question
it is impossible to have cooperation
between a senior senior General so a
senior command of army with precaution
absolutely not they hate him and they of
course just eager to to liquidate him
the problem could be with the with the I
would say a junior officers on the
battlefield who can demonstrate sympathy
to precaution because of problems
they're facing on a battlefield the
problem with the supplies and the just
operational or coordinated commands and
all other many many assets that's that's
what I'm saying just on a junior Ephesus
they could they could somehow create
sympathy but on a higher level
absolutely impossible that's why just
there will be an interesting period
within this upcoming two days how just
Putin will be able to stop this military
military I would say cool whatever what
we can use of for these precautions
attempt to to to to change to change I
would say the leadership of Ministry of
Defense configuration
and it'd be interesting to see won't it
um in reality what the relationship
between pragodin and the gru is because
that could be a critical power dynamic
exactly exactly exactly and right now
just of course as I said all all the
propaganda machines will be mobilized
against precaution and just the issue is
just how far precaution could move and
how I would say hush measures Putin can
undertake against this military group
whether they will be bombing them just
or just but other things but precaution
said they are not going they're going
not going to confess not going to accept
any I would say I would say can
conversation a quiet conversation and to
to accept uh Putin's requirement to stop
this operation and just to to to be
recognized as as a traitors and in fact
that already just the criminal case
already opened by General Prosecutor
Office it means just for precaution
could could be put in jail for for 12 15
years at least if not liquidated
persons Focus as you're saying is going
to be 100 on trying to push put this
down where does this leave the assault
in Ukraine
uh in fact that that's now now happening
without uh I'll say emotions as a as uh
I would say defeats uh coming and on a
battlefield on a war against Ukraine but
on a later stage such a conflict would
be even harder and deeper and in fact of
course a successful military operation
uh Contra contribution counter offensive
operation of uh Ukrainian Army that will
be the trigger for further problems in
in the Putin cities or ruling if we can
call this name by their name that's what
we should expect just further problems
in Russia and moreover in the in in in
the coming Autumn Kuching had to
announce that he is going for for the
next presidential term and he would like
just to get support of Army and all
people and what is going on uh taking
place right now of course uh playing
against this and that's why Putin will
be nervous even more than that and that
would be we shall see development and
within few days and then later as a
result of successful Contra offense
recreational Ukraine
what do you think will happen if Wagner
forces do descend on Moscow in in the
next day or two uh uh I don't believe
they will they will come of course just
uh Putin's militaries will will create
everything not to happen this so that it
will not happen and that's why just I
don't expect such such things there's
already closed two roads uh coming to
Moscow as I said just highway from
rustoff Dawn and Highway from Crimea
they already closed those bridges over
Moscow River so that these two main
roads are really close for any
transportation just not necessarily just
only for for Wagner's but Wagner's right
now in varonias which is 600 kilometers
from Moscow but I don't think they will
be able to move to Moscow they they're
not they're not so capable to to to to
to to create such a problem such a big
problem all right Mikhail kazanov thank
you very much for talking to us on Sky
News thank you